I'm poised on dro and we have a very
special pennyworth interview with the
cast of pennyworth for collider heroes I
am so excited guys I love this show
thank you first no thank you
I I want to know as we were just saying
this is your first comic-con this year
what was it like to be not only
promoting a comic book show but in San
Diego looking at giant billboards of
your work it was insane it was yeah it's
our first time and we went we went
Wednesday to Saturday and I walked the
convention floor on Wednesday because
because it premiered at the Sunday after
Comic Con so no one knew who we were and
it was great and I was walking through
the convention floor at the Warner
Brothers stage and suddenly like a
30-foot me pop run away but they
screened it on the Wednesday night and
then we did our panel on the Friday so
Saturday people started to be like
asking for photos and things like that
now with this show we have a unique
perspective to tell a story that's never
been told were you guys fans of these
characters beforehand no cuz I mean you
play Alfred Pennyworth who is a
legendary character in his own right and
Thomas Wayne is a legacy that is
legendary in its own right
were those characters who are familiar
with personally huge fan of all those
death scenes yeah a grand gun huge fans
I don't think I knew a huge amount about
about Thomas Wayne but definitely
definitely a Batman of DC and if comic
books in in general yeah for sure I was
excited to you know to be to be joining
that world to work on a show it involves
that for sure yeah I mean my my Alfred
generationally was was Michael Caine
really and those the Christopher Nolan
films for me was what what brought me to
it I didn't I didn't read comics a lot
growing up but I've come to it you know
as a result of this show yeah you both
basically paid father-figure to Bruce
Wayne one as a legacy father figure and
one is a more literal father figure so
you're kind of retro actively building
Bruce Wayne up are there seeds you're
planning from the mythos of pop culture
Batman that you're retro actively adding
as his father figures in the two
from formats I think Bruno Heller that
showing a creator
yeah I think he's got his eyes on on
that prize in terms of like plotting in
personality traits and bits of DNA and
things that you can recognize from
certainly from Alfred and I think from
from Thomas way and then Martha Kane
who's part of a story yeah obviously
will become Martha Wayne so yeah I think
he's definitely what his eyes on doing
that doing a bit for foreshadowing
that's the word
well shadow we're trying to find it
worth about two weeks so you kind of are
there more on hand father figure for
Bruce and you have to be this darkly
comic but also very physical character
and and you lay so much groundwork
because you've been played by such
legends like Michael go and Jeremy Irons
and Michael Caine when you were building
that character did you look to their
work or did you try to keep it to your
own well we had a conversation Bruno had
a showrunner Danny cannon a lead
director and exact producer and they
sort of you know we we kept landing on
Michael Caine because he gave us he said
I'll play a butler as long as he's
ex-sas so he gives us that backstory
which we explore in penny Watson so that
we if there were any we were nodding to
him and also because he was like the
British film star of the sixties so in
terms of pop culture we had loads of
films that he'd done anyway that's
perfect from the Ipcress file and stuff
where he's actually playing a spy and
he's got a gun you know so it was
fantastic wealth of knowledge there in
that respect Alfred and Michael keen to
loo kind of a while and then it yeah it
was it was great now for me I've always
said that Luther is my favorite Batman
show Luther with Aegis Elba I always
feel like he's effectively the world's
greatest detective and he's taking out
these super villains so when I watch
Luther I'm watching the goddamn Batman
this to me feels like as much a prequel
to Luther as it does Harry Brown Batman
and I love the fact that this is so and
as a-- as an american british yeah is is
there someone on set that's basically
keeping things through a through line or
you guys get to play with dialogue is
the script written like the slang the
pace everything feels like that that
authenticity that that i only get to
experience when it's not right right
that comes from Bruno had a I'm 100%
he's he's British he's lived in LA for
twenty thirty years but the the great
thing about the show is it has this
almost nostalgia to a time it's a love
letter to Britain and I must stress that
it's a weird 1960s London but they're
certainly yeah the bits in there and the
authenticity and the bits that you think
that is quintessentially British that's
that's Bruno really I mean of course we
get to Terrence a bit but I'd dint
really cuz he's so good you can kind you
can kind of feel him enjoying that walks
I think he's written he's written for
the American accent and for American
people for the last like 15 years I
think so you can kind of fill him
relishing like thinking back to the
1960s how people spoke and he's very
very good each character has a very
distinct voice and a lot of detail in
there so yeah yeah the supporting cast
gets a lot of time to shine and grow
their arcs especially like Episode three
you spend a lot of time with those two
at the bar like your fellow SAS members
and you really get to live and grow with
them and I love that I love long-form TV
because you get to build an entire
family and this show does that really
well and it feels like the character of
London is a character absolutely yeah
and I love that it balances there's
moments where it's straight-up James
Bond and then they'll be like a 60s
Batman moment where like this scene was
Ripper that just suddenly goes like
hijinks yeah yeah yeah was that
something that when you were first
reading the scripts was that alarming
did it translate on the page where there
was suddenly being like a tonal shift or
did it work both on page and screen I
think it I think it was there I don't
think I was clever enough to see it
initially when I was reading I sometimes
I'd read it we'd get to the scene and
Danny
or whoever was directing we had lots of
great directors would would pull that
out of the script and I go there that's
brilliant
you know and especially you know when
you're doing a first season of something
like this and you'll you know you're
working out who these characters are
you're also working out what the world
is and you're you're I remember
sometimes being like can is this funny
what have I do this is that okay like we
allowed to do that and I remember when
we watched the pilot for the first time
being surprised pleased how funny it is
I had no idea it's gonna be as as funny
that little granny that comes out with
the gun tiny little jokes in there that
having read it didn't didn't ping out
watching you I was like they're very
funny visual moments as well the comedy
is so necessary because it's so depraved
and it's a much darker show than I
expected and Batman is an impossibly
dark character when done right but this
doesn't feel gratuitous while being
completely violent was it an intense set
was it very high stakes or was it
relaxed just the dialogue makes it
intense like was the work day like 18
hours and it all feel like work I mean
there were long days sure but it it was
a joy to go to work every day and I
think it's fantastic because we shot it
all in London so it was like our little
secret so long and we got everyone went
home at the end of every day and
weekends with friends and family rather
than if you shoot somewhere on away from
home you know you're all together so
actually it was very relaxed yeah wasn't
it and people will you know I remember
everyone's sort of like this is a few
weeks in and being like this is like
this is okay rather than I always
thought because this is a big career
jump for me you know I thought when
something like this would would come I'd
I'd be petrified and it would be you
know you terrible you know
stress and but everyone was so good at
their jobs that it made it actually a
joyous experience really now you play
the American who stands out like a sore
thumb
Thomas Wayne every time every time you
appear it's almost like the lighting of
America
Thomas awesome especially in the first
episode because we've met this world
we've dove into London the character and
then every time you there it's just like
mustache yes Batman mythos but he's got
a lot less screen time than Alfred has
yeah I've got to develop your own take
in the character a bit more who do you
see Thomas Wayne as well the starting
point when I didn't recall for Danny and
Bruno they start talking about Cary
Grant so they want him to feel like that
kind of a slice of old-school Hollywood
so I started there getting in anyway
it's an impression of him at all or
anything but I was like yeah I'll try
and get some of that kind of Hollywood
glamour suaveness into it and then
really Bruno had written in such detail
who he was on the page and also I was
discovering as well so that there you
know he goes on this whole journey and I
didn't know that journey I only knew
episode 2 episode so I didn't know the
end point of that at all and sometimes I
pushed him into this but sometimes I
didn't necessarily know the truth which
I think they did I think they kind of
played a bit of a game with me and
didn't give me all the information on
purpose
so episode 1 I'm playing one thing and
then episode 3 I was like okay that's
that's cool but actually it kind of
worked and when you win so he's kind of
involved in this kind of covert
underground world and when you're
working for those agencies if you're at
the center of it you often don't know
what's going on or what the truth is so
it was like using that to my advantage
and discovering out where you went along
which is quite exciting and we were all
doing that I think so too episode
because your characters kept in the dark
and you're kept in the dark so it works
for me yeah yeah and we also just didn't
know what the am result of all of these
things were gonna be until we read them
so yeah it's an exciting way to film it
I like that Cary Grant charm versus the
Michael Caine there's this established
difference between like the the British
version of like comfortable and
collected versus an American and that
dichotomy especially in the beginning
really plays as you guys form a bond
that's the most unlikely of the show and
it's a really cool thing to see this
shows tone because I'm straight-up like
this is probably my favorite show of
2019 favorite new show know
to watch content for a living so I and
this really for me surprised me because
I never would have thought a prequel to
one of my favorite characters would be
so its own entity it doesn't feel like
you know anything at all to watch the
end the first movie the first episode
feels like a movie yeah what was the
tone like changing directors how much
did they communicate was the writer like
this there's a beating heart to this
that's incredibly consistent and I think
it sounds it's like a love letter to
Bruno but that's Bruno because yeah bro
aside from episode seven and eight he
wrote all of it and he was he was there
you know sort of throughout but we had
Danny cannon set such a fantastic tone
at the beginning we had great do peas
and and really fantastic camera
operators that you know everyone I think
the thing for me was this description on
page three of the pilot script where
Bruno described this 1960s London and he
described it to such detail and it's
such a good idea
that everyone really invested in that
and and from you know I there was a
great production designer Marc Scruton
who for me that was the final piece of
the puzzle you you you're looking at you
know these these guys voices how they
move what they wear and stuff like that
but once we stepped onto these sets or
the locations that were dressed that for
me I immediately understood the world
and what we were going for that was the
final bit for me so I think it's such a
strong flavor as it were yes that it's
kind of easy to to stick with it but um
it was really great working with lots of
brilliant directors and every couple of
weeks getting a new energy on set and
and navigating that you know it's great
yeah I think like they're the world that
he created is so strong they just
basically had the stick to that world it
has its own political system it's got an
entertainment system they they they
televised that hanging out quite weird
and also into a sheepherding was a good
sheepdog try
yeah is one of
like this the society seems to be in
these weird things that aren't like our
world at all and they're never explained
they never explain that is that one of
my favorite things the anachronism the
anachronism show where you're watching a
show and all of a sudden you'll hear a
song from the 90s but a remix like a
cover effectively of the time period
yeah and that the first visual and I saw
was the hanging I was like wait I love
that sorry early 1900 but I love that it
feels like an else world but in the
comic books there's these little pockets
where you can have like Batman by
Gaslamp where you have another world
when you dive in and this feels like
Gotham by way of London by way of an
invention of their own so it always
still feels like a Batman show while not
needing to be a Batman show yeah it's
interesting I think you know really this
could be a show about a young guy who's
been in the army leaves sets up a
security firm today it's the sexy
American but it just so happens that
he's called Alfred playing off he's
caught someone's waiting and we of
course know what happens you know and so
we just sort of Nixon names from the
Canon of filling in the backstory but
really it could be like one of my the
Fast Five I love dearly the the fast
furious Brazilian job was originally
turned into Fast Five like the Italian
Job movie got turned into the Fast Five
so it's the more thing where they were
able to use the names build the legacy
and it's its own beating hearts its own
entity and I think this show captures
that in a way that I've not seen a lot
of comic shows do yeah what was it like
day-to-day as not lifelong comic book
fans to see these familiar names like
when Martha Kane popped up in the title
I lost my mind because I knew I knew
what that meant I knew it was to come
were there moments where you recognize
the name like oh right that thing from
that time from like yeah there was some
stuff that we I was that's good but
though we had one one actor on set yeah
hainsley who plays baza
is a comic book fan so watching his face
light up
you understand what this means yeah not
really I mean that's great but I had
this one moment at the club I think
probably doing exactly that position at
the bar in between takes copying you and
there was a background artists that
started having a little chat with me and
then you're just talking about showing
how excited he wasn't any kind of turn
ters his friend he was like I just spoke
to Thomas wing I was like oh I guess
that's a big thing he's awfully into
comic books but yeah so that was kind of
little moment I guess we'd realized the
magnitude of it for for that whole fan
fan group and Thomas Wayne is very
prevalent right now he's back in the
comics in this home King turn a Batman
Thomas Wayne is like dragging Bruce
Wayne through a desert as we speak he's
back in like the comic book zeitgeist
because of different earth to stuff so
these characters are yeah like right now
you're killing it's a whole else world
thing right yeah I've had I've had well
I had flashpoint mentioned to me a few
times and I brought it up to Bruno being
like season 2 we do that maybe the
comeback before Batman and I think it
will happen I'll keep trying to pitch in
just same thing 20/20 just in bed yes
Batsy sabotage is there anywhere you
want these characters to go I don't I
haven't seen the end of the season so
I'm not I don't know any more than you
do but is there anywhere you want these
characters to go that you feel like
they've developed to that it would be
different between from like where we
start in season 1 I'm very excited I
think Alfred's sort of goes from a boy
to a man across the series and you know
it's difficult knowing what to say about
not to say but I'm I'm excited i I want
him to learn how to make a good cup of
tea maybe add small ambitions
episode maybe Thomas gets I feel like it
gets increasingly cynical throughout
this this series and some kind of very
unexpected twists and turns happen for
him around Episode seven eight which
throw him into a new place I kind of I
kind of would like to continue going
darker with him I think we'll see where
it ends up but we know he ends up is his
upstanding philanthropist he lives in
Gotham and gives money to everyone in
these you know essentially good I would
I'm more interested in seeing how he
ends up there but hopefully it goes
darker before he goes lighter yeah you
both nosey but you're at a and B right
now letters to get there to see what
happens in the middle yeah one of the
things I really like is the show values
intelligence all the characters are
smart all the characters speak well but
they're also clever they're not just
smart there's their Street smart all of
them and one of my favorite scenes so
far was the one where you basically
handled the entire gang outside the
airport hangar with wittiness yeah yeah
it's a problem solved was the script
punchy like that like it has the Sorkin
beat to it I keep going back to the the
productive like action team but yeah it
was it all there or did it like develop
on the day that was 100% make a cup of
tea yeah that was one of my favorite
things about reading the scripts was
that how is he gonna get out of this one
and Bruno always always had something
very clever up his sleeve but I think
yeah that that moment in in episode 3
one of the producers said to me when we
were filming it was like as Alfred you
got in the script Alfred talks in like
your your senses are like 2 2 words long
yeah I paid two pages of Jack's dialogue
would be like three words four words
Thomas speaks in massive paragraphs
because it's way cool
I've got loads to learn they have like
five page scenes where don't stop
talking the whole time versus this very
cool strip back you know in a rap part
we had a blooper reel which consisted
just of me the place day for as well
just us I think because I had so much
messing up never got anything wrong
[Laughter]
now these characters you both have to
develop very specific accents like the I
love the Michael Caine influence that
didn't feel like it was just you doing a
Michael Caine impression but I
definitely felt Michael came come
through that character that was so much
fun to see and you had to develop a
completely different world and you're
authentically American like when I met
you today I was a little like okay I had
no idea I would have assumed so was
there anything that you guys found that
surprised you in developing these
characters like accent wise as actors
I think can't I think from me I I went
back and looked at Cary Grant movies and
a few other actors that of that time as
well and they they all spoke crazy I was
actually watching all about Eve on the
plane yes and the way don't know why
dipped into some classics and was
listening to their voices and those
transatlantic accents were something
else that we don't have at all now and
all actors had to develop their own kind
of vocal pattern and they were kind of
known for that whereas I don't think we
are so much as actors called upon to do
that now but I'm looking at his accents
I didn't want to think transatlantic one
do something purely American but yeah I
went a nod to the period and that was
kind of in the rhythm in and how and how
they speak and I think well yeah he
speaks and so quite specific rhythm I
think some people have been like well
that's not new to American accent but of
the time in the 50s and 60s there were
there was there were more people that
were speaking like that I think I hope
[Laughter]
so was I surprised me but that was that
was a challenge or something
yeah come for sure yeah I don't think
there were too many surprises I just
again it was almost written like you
said there's one or two words a sentence
you know it's full stops and to the
point and the one thing that surprised
me was
I did while I tried not to make it to
statement II you know and it was trying
to keep it fresh in that respect but it
was almost written phonetically and it
was very clear as to how they wanted me
to do it I think as much as the violence
is amazing as much as the directing the
dialogue sings the show is a beautiful
thing to listen to and watch so favorite
show 2019 so far guys straight-up like
no exaggeration I am in love with the
show thank you so much for doing these
legendary characters justice